ابدا معك بهذا الاعلان للجيش الاسرائيلي
عن مقتل ضابط وجندي واصابه ثلاثه عسكريين
اخرين يعني هذا النوع من الاعلانات في
الصباح بت امر شبه يومي يبدا الجيش باعلان
عدد ثم تتوالى الاعداد دون الافصاح عن
الحصيله مباشره يعني الحصيله العامه الى
ماذا يعود ذلك في
اعتقادك تحياتي لك استاذه سهام و
للمشاهدين يعني ال حين يعلن الناطق
العسكري لا يعلن انه قتل الجندي فلان او
علان بالمعركه انما يقول سمح للنشر عن
مقتل فلان الفلاني بمعنى انه انه هنالك
قتلى اخرين لكن لم يتم السماح بالنشر
وهنالك الكثير من الاسباب لعدم النشر جزء
منها
تتم بالتفاهم والاتفاق مع مع عائلات وذوي
القتلى جزء لانه بيكون مرتزقه جزء من اصول
غير يهوديه وبالتالي يفضلوا عدم الاعلان
ان قتل ابنائهم في غزه وجزء من الخارج
اولئك الذين يتم تسميتهم بال بالحادي
العائلات انه لا توجد لهم عائلات هنا
باسرائيل بمعنى انه انه العدد الحقيقي
يعني
اي اكبر بكثير مما مما يعلن وانه الاعلان
انه الناطق
العسكري بلسان جيش الاحتلال يعزز بشكل
واضح ثقه المجتمع الفلسطيني بما يصدر من
بيانات وبلاغات عن المقاومه الفلسطينيه
كما نشرتم قبل لحظات سواء عن كتائب القسام
او او سرايا القدس بكل الاحوال الاعتراف
والاعلان الاسرائيلي اضاف انه يراد منه
الحفاظ الى حد ما على اي ثقه المجتمع
اليهودي او ما تبقى من ثقه لدى المجتمع
اليهودي تجاه الروايه العسكريه وما يصدر
عنها من بيانات ومن خطاب وخاصه انه في
الاسبوع الماضي يعني شاهدنا الكثير من
الكتابات التي صدرت عن عن عن الكثير من من
الاكاديميين والخبراء العسكريين الذين
باتوا يشككوا بشكل واضح بكل ما صدر عن
المؤسسه العسكريه منذ اليوم الاول ل الحرب
وحتى يومنا هذا وخاصه هل يمكن بالفعل
اخفاء الحصيله الحقيقيه رغم تسريبات
المستشفيات ووسائل الاعلام وايضا وجوب
القيام
بجنازته لهؤلاء
القتلى يعني بالامكان هنالك الكثير من من
الوسائل الت يتم من خلالها اخفاء و يعني
هذا ليس جديدا معروف عن اسرائيل انه انه
انها تخفي وخاصه انه الاعلان عن كل
الخسائر الاسرائيليه هذا من شانه ان يؤدي
الى تعزيز ثقه المقاومه الفلسطينيه بذاتها
وان يعزز ثقه الشعب الفلسطيني بالمقاومه
وان يشكل رافعه وحافز ودافعيه قويه
للاستمرار طالما انها تنجز كذلك وان ان
الاسرائيل يعترف وبالجانب الاخر انه
الاعلان والاعتراف بكل عن كل القتل
والخسائر من شانه ان يضرب معنويات الجنود
وان يضرب معنويات المجتمع اليهودي وموضوع
ووع تماسك المجتمع اليهودي
وبقاءه داعم للحرب من اهم شروط ومتطلبات
الحرب اسرائيل بحاجه دعميني امريكي تحديدا
ودعم داخلي دعم المجتمع اليهودي دعم
المجتمع اليهودي يعني يعني مرتبط بشكل
كبير جدا بما يحدث بالميدان وتحديدا
بالخسائر وفي في هذا الاطار ايضا بالاضافه
الى الخسائر في اعتقادك السحب لواء جولاني
من ارض المعركه كيف سيؤثر على معنويات
الجيش والمجتمع الاسرائيلي في هذه
المرحله يعني اصلا اذا اعلن عن سحب لواء
جولاني وما يشكل بال بالوعي الاسرائيلي
وما ينظر اليه اسرائيليا من قدرات قتاليه
بالتاكيد هذا مؤشر على تدني معنويات هذه
الكتيبه كتيبه 13 المعروفه في في اسرائيل
وخاصه انه يعني يعني كما يعلم الجميع انه
انه خسرت الكثير هي الكتيبه تحديدا يعني
خسرت 44 جندي وقائدها ونائب قائدها بفتره
زمنيه شهرين شهرين ونصف
ومظهر الفرحه الذي بدا على الجنود في في
في اثناء الاحتفال الذي عمل لهم الليله
الماضيه في احدى الكيبوتسات في المحيطه
بقطاع غزه يفهم باتجاهين اما انهم بالفعل
فرحين انه تم اخراجهم من من من من من من ه
المعارك الضاريه والتي فقدوا 44 قتيلا
واكيد اضعافه من من من الجرحى والمصابين
او انه الاسرائيلي الذي عمل كل هذا
التضخيم الاعلامي وتم بث ونشر وتصوير
الاحتفال وخروجهم يعني وهم مبتسمين اراد
ان يوصل رساله طمانه للمجتمع اليهودي ان
الجنود يعني معنوياتهم عاليه وخاصه انه
سبق ذلك بالايام القيله الماضيه قيام كل
وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه بالاتصال وحتى
وحتى استدعاء الكثير من الجنود والضباط
الى استديوهات المحطات الاسرائيليه
والحديث انهم مرتاحين ومستمرين بالقتال
ومعنوياتهم عاليه
ويواصلون توجيه ضربات للحماس وللجهات
وفجروا انفاق وصادروا اسلحه وما شابه واضح
تماما انه هذا ياتي انعكاسا يعني وترجمه
دقيقه للواقع الصعب الذي يعيشه الجنود
وخاصه ان ان اول حرب بتاريخ اسرائيل
يخوضها الجيش الاسرائيلي بهذا الواقع
العمراني المقتص يعني يعني بنايات مكتظه
ثم الخطا الذي بدا الكثير من الاسرائيليين
يتحدث عنه هو هذا الحجم الكبير من الدمار
الذي يعني احدثته الطائرات الاسرائيليه
والدبابات والتي حولت هذا الركام الى شبه
انفاق او او ملاجئ او حصون يتحصن بها
المقاتلين و ويخرجون
ويبغون الجيش مما مما ادى الى تحويل حياه
الجنود الى كوابيس في في في غزه خبر سحب
لواء جولاني جاء بالتزامن مع فيديو عرضته
كتائب القسام لثلاثه اسرى تقول ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي قتلهم بسلاحه وطبعا اظهرت
صورهم
و اجزاء من حياتهم اليوميه في الاسر
السؤال هو في اعتقادك كيف يمكن لمشاهد
كهذه ان تؤثر على الراي العام الاسرائيلي
وبالتالي ان تؤثر على موضوع التعامل
الاسرائيلي مع قضيه
الاسرى يعني بالتاكيد هذا مساله مهمه جدا
والحرب على الوعي والحرب الاعلاميه هي من
اهم مكونات الحرب واستمراريتها ومدى
قدرتها على فرض ذاتها بالميدان وخاصه انه
نشر ه المقاطع له الكثير من الانعكاسات
اولاها تضرب معنويات ال المجتمع اليهودي
وتعيد طرح موضوع الاسرى الاسرائيليين
الموجودين بغزه لطاوله النقاش في في
اسرائيل و و تزيد حجم التفاعل المجتمعي
طالما ان انهم على يعني على قيد الحياه
جزء منهم وجزء كانوا على قيد الحياه ولكن
الغارات الاسرائيليه ادت الى مقتلهم
والاهم من ذلك انها تضع الحكومه والجيش في
موقف محرج امام المجتمع اليهودي وتظهرهم
انهم عاجزين او غير
معنيين لاعاده اسراهم بالتالي لذلك نلاحظ
احنا انه حمله اسرائيليه شرسه بعد كل نشر
فيديو وتكون هنالك محاولات لحجب هذا الماق
هي المقاطع عن ال
اي الاجهزه الاسرائيليه و مناشده المجتمع
اليهودي بعدم التطرق لها و ووصفها بانها
يعني جزء من من الارهاب الدعائي لحماس وما
شابه هذا يؤكد انه تاثير نشر هذه المقاطع
تاثير كبير وقوي على المستوى العسكري
والسياسي الذي يظهر عاجز او غير او غير
معني عن عن اعادتهم وامام المجتمع اليهودي
وخاصه انه المجتمع اليهودي يبدي حساسيه
كبرى تجاه اي اسرائيلي ايا كان كان موجود
لدى المقاومه الفلسطينيه حتى وان كانوا
جثث فما بالك حين يكونوا على قيد الحياه
وهنالك خشيه وخوف حقيقي على حياتهم ليس من
الاثرين انما من من من جيش الاحتلال
وغارات